hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Lauren
gah alright so we're gonna watch the
trailer for if I stay the second trailer
I don't know what that is it stars Chloe
grace Moretz okay yeah it's like a
cheesy a romantic movie you're I usually
like those I know right do it let's do
it
I'm so crazy in love with you so mean
because I like to let you play you go to
another face you get this crease in your
forehead right there honey
you might just be staring down the
barrel of greatness so try to stay open
to it don't go closing their doors on
yourself
how come you never written a song for me
I'm not gonna writing about things that
made me happy favorite musicians we
could just go to college together
sorry inconvenient to fall in love at
your age especially if it's the realty
price me know where you are about where
I am
don't spend next two years together guys
never in an amazing how life is one
thing and then in an instant it becomes
something else like Here I am Mia the
girl who thinks about the cello and Adam
and Juilliard and just like that could
never exist again my dying is that what
this is what females critical on with
the Portland now somebody talk to me
please help me say something I'm giving
up on you poor kids waking up an orphan
if she wakes up
use the secret baby if you teach it's
all up to you
oh how can I stay without mom and dad
how can I leave without Adam how am I
supposed to decide this
[Music]
life is this big fat gigantic mass
that's the beauty of it - yeah please I
wanna feel you touch me I don't have to
think I can fix what happened she can't
do anything he loves you with everybody
gone
that might be too hard for you to keep
fighting but I want you to live well Mia
stay say something are you crying no
okay no I I told you I loved you to be
like so cheesy okay well I need look
super duper cheesy I can't write things
that make me happy
first of all can I say that this is what
is wrong with what this is why girls
that grow up and think that this [ __ ] is
real are like all [ __ ] up when they're
dogs that's all I'm gonna start with
well when girls finally get that guy
they don't respond well to it they don't
they always go oh no that's just my
friend no that's how it works
no it's not that there's that guy it's
just that that thing that they have
Israel and I'm sure that it is real for
some people but when girls watch these
movies they think that that's like that
it's so easy but it's as easy as it was
in the movie but it's a [ __ ] movie
anyway seven mad about the movies betray
me don't know but seriously I think of
it especially for our generation girls
that grew up on Disney movies like
Disney Princess movies yes I think that
like things like all the movies that we
watch like affect how we see the world I
agree I agree after avatar I did not
want to [ __ ] with Indians anymore is it
thankful good I think that's what it was
supposed to do that is you that is exact
feeling I got and I stopped [ __ ] with
their needs right away okay dad well
yeah I pissed off a lot of Indian system
back in today yeah spray-painted
he pieces but tbh their TVs ah anyway uh
yeah this movie okay this the first
trailer did something similar which was
it's just a bunch of love cheese and
then the whole she might die stuff which
always wins me over in that moment like
I'm watching the trailer I'm like okay
this looks so stupid no but they have to
set it up that way that it's like Oh
their life is so perfect and that's why
you like I knew that something was gonna
go wrong it just seems so unreal let's
take them talks like that to each other
this is sad that like these teenage
preteen girls are like watching this
movie and like like oh my god no people
don't talk like that
real life isn't like that sorry kids
just that guy seems so ridiculously
cheesy they both seem cheesy it's a
cheesy romantic movie that's what it is
if that's what you want to watch I mean
the notebook is a cheesy romantic movie
but that isn't yeah they they made those
rules a little believable in this one
it's like dude how [ __ ] like stearic
this it's like they took all the cliches
and they combine it into one guy I love
the fact that Chloe grace Moretz is I
use a your name alright Moretz Moretz
that she plays the cello like very
unusual instrument to choose but kudos
life is tough cuz I'm so disciplined but
this boy's so free and he's kind of
depressed and mysterious but he loves me
Bandon I mean it looks exactly like I
bet it is exactly like what it looks
like so if that's what you're into cool
go see it I'm gonna watch it I tend to
enjoy movies like this I like I've told
you like three times right I love
romantic movies so alright guys well
thanks for letting us know that trailer
was out I can't wait to have a cheesy
good time I enjoyed watching the trailer
I know you got teary eyed and that was
crazy it was very sweet in the end and
then she's like dying and then what what
maybe you wrote a swim free
Metiria is when I guess it's her
grandfather or something when I was like
so it said something about like how it'd
be hard to fight or something that's
what yeah yeah that that was a good
moment that that is a rare good moment
that was probably the only thing that
hit us because that was the part with
the best acting exactly exactly who is
this actor I want to find out who that
kid is destroy his reputation
how should be the next big thing I know
oh yeah if you're new to the channel
that's good subscribe and Lauren has her
own I do she's actually doing stuff with
it yeah right so subscribe to her
Channel yeah do it man do it it'll be
well worth every moment of your life
every single note at every moment just
stay on YouTube we can give a shout-out
to rabid dingo
let's do right now yeah rabid dingo
rabid dingo requested a shout-out from
me yeah so here it is hey rabid dingo
thanks for watching and thanks for being
a fan and being my fan he really likes
you he's been in wanting a shout-out
from me for a long time really I'm sorry
it took so long but Ryan's not very
organized at the shoutout list no I
brought it up because he like sent it to
me that that you rabid dingo requested
as he said he was like really
heartbroken let me see if I could find a
very sympathetic towards that oh no what
don't be heartbroken
rabbit dingo it has been so long that I
have waited for a Lauryn shoutout but
alas I have been denied promises are
given yet not completed I stand alone in
an ocean of silence please bring forth
her beautiful voice Wow
very poetic wow you do dude you might
have the five qualities that it takes no
simple 5 simplify simple 5 just do that
by I think just watch her video on her
channel all you guys right now you are
interested in her
it's go on her channel watch that video
and you'll learn
how to get Lauren say something um
forgot the lyric give it up on you
that's it that's all I remember I don't
remember the lyrics I I can't even
remember the chorus main code reckless
fusion hey reckless fusion you guys are
amazing
shout out yeah reckless fusion you can
get a shout out because you're you're
out of control man you're a little bit
reckless though yeah tone it down
don't just a little bit just a little
bit man going thank you first it's not
the [ __ ] purge okay you can't just go
around doing crazy [ __ ] like that
anymore man
you gotta calm down before you seriously
hurt someone I mean you have hurt people
[Music]
reckless fusions a murderer oh my god
this is what you call good acting from
both for Nina we should be proud of
ourselves this is like that was like
real art like we really believed that
reckless fusion was the murderer for a
second okay moving on
Antonio Corona Antonio Corona I gotta
read this oh my god you guys are [ __ ]
awesome Ryan you are awesome you're so
hilarious LMFAO but guys I was wrong if
I could have a shout-out my birthday was
on July 18 I'm 13 years old I know I'm
young but can I please have a shout-out
or replay you guys are the best
Antonio Corona you're getting a
shout-out for your birthday you are
officially a teenager how does it feel I
know in some traditions you are a man oh
yes go get bar Mitzvahed yeah that's it
how they say it that's how they tell you
to do get Bar Mitzvah huh yeah sex out
make you a man also don't do that you
have no have sex have sex as soon as you
can earlier you start the better I'm
telling you that I'm a terrible idea
don't worry about condoms either you're
13 you can't produce a baby it's
physically not possible he's lying so go
out there have sex my condoms enjoy it
while you can it's like I gave rabid
dingo advice just go on Lawrence five
qualities most attractive in a guy and
if you apply those qualities you'll get
a lot of girls it's good to start now I
wish I had that advice
that was your race stardom young start
him young I was just watching a bunch of
porn when I was 13 I didn't get actual
girls a lot of asian porn chinese girls
nice things a lot
yeah really does well you look really
good in that dress today thank you
I kind of like it when you're a little
bit you know not responsive to my
advances it kind of makes me want you
more [ __ ] yeah we talked about this in
my video open about you being [ __ ]
it's just gotta stop being so nice so
sexy anyway
Antonio happy birthday man see ya yeah
jerk off have some fun go Canada girl oh
god if I had to be 13
I would so do that again yeah what would
you redo
I don't even know how to redo anything
anything that I've done in my life up to
this point but if I could like relive it
okay okay if I could tell my 13 year old
self something it would be don't take
life so seriously because I feel like
when I was that age you know you think
that everything is the end of the world
but it's not who gives the [ __ ] whatever
whoever else thinks just do what makes
you happy and be yourself sincerity yeah
that's what that's that's my advice to
you Antonio we rarely have sincerity on
this channel what I'm always sincere I
know I know
wow this is crazy okay well yeah I'm
Toni I don't give a [ __ ] what people
think just do what you gotta do you do
you yeah you do you
shut up